[Music]
all right we continue Hannity with our
town hall we are in beautiful Acworth
Georgia Herschel Walker still is with us
and we're now joined by Senator Lindsey
Graham and Senator Tim Scott both from
the great state of South Carolina
both of you have been really really
supportive of herschel's campaign and by
the way so is every Republican I meet no
let's talk about Senator Scott here's a
common sense conservative who's doing
the right thing understands business has
signed the front of a paycheck and not
just a back if we want to help Georgians
and all of America let's start winning
the majority right here in Georgia
we're right here in Georgia where's the
Walker
Sean by the way I think it's important
for people to know you're up for
re-election absolutely but you're coming
down here because this race is important
to you so important to me I tell you I
was a fan of Herschel I was a a weaker
running back
he won the Heisman trophy
anyways I did not so but think about
this though think about someone who
understands and appreciates the hard
side of the track someone who came up in
Wrightsville Georgia who understands
poverty who understands tenacity
and to go the extra mile for your fellow
citizen someone who did it on the field
but off the field someone who did it in
business but also in the non-profit
World here's a guy who's willing to put
his life on the line for this great
nation because he understands the value
of American citizenship I can't think of
a better place to be in all of America
than right here in Georgia
I had a conversation with you off air
when Hersha was considering getting into
this race yeah and and we had discussed
it I said I'm going to kick your ass if
you don't run yeah and he did say that
he did say that but we all know that's a
joke
all right now could I have done it I
doubt it but I said it so and we talked
about the fact that Herschel was such an
open book he talked about his his life
the struggles his his time and I said
Lindsay they're going to go after him
with everything they've got they have
done dumped from money outside of
Georgia by the way so yeah all of it
they have done tens and tens of millions
of dollars in negative ads to smear
slander besmerge and destroy the
character of this man yeah I I've seen
bad campaigns in the past this is one of
the worst well I've seen this movie
before remember Kavanaugh
aren't you tired of this crap you know
why I'm here tonight because the two
senators you have cancel out our votes
yes right the people in South Carolina
are pulling for you Herschel because
there must be something different in the
water between the two states but I don't
think so you got a chance here to right
or wrong
one more Senator means that Tim is the
chairman of the Banking Committee not
Sherrod Brown
if we're in if we're in the majority I'm
chairman of the budget committee not
Bernie Sanders
foreign
have to like me that's a good reason to
vote already 90 million dollars raised
against Herschel he's raised 32 which is
a lot of money we're going to close that
Gap tonight team herschel.com folks help
this man in the last two minutes
stevehurstle.com so so he could take it
Sean what did they do to Kavanaugh right
at the very end when the hearing is
about over oh we got this letter
well the media had had the letter nobody
allowed Kavanaugh to answer the letter
every day was somebody new some thank
God for Sean Hannity who allows you to
get the other side of the story out
right yeah so
we gonna close strong Herschel the
debate was awesome
you did a good I tell you what
I'm not a big dodgeball fan but if
there's a Heisman trophy for Dodgeball
Warren it gets it this guy wouldn't even
answer what where are you from I don't
know
so with herschel's what you see is what
you get one more seat we stop all this
madness Biden said eating ice cream in
Washington the economy's strong as hell
you don't don't you think he's missing a
lot oh yeah so if you won't change don't
vote for the same thing absolutely now
people in South Carolina are pulling for
Herschel because the two senators why
fire votes out you've had everything but
the kitchen sink thrown at you you're
still standing you're a good man you're
going to win this race name herschel.com
go light up the internet team
herschel.com close the gap yes and uh
I'll say this think about this just two
years ago we were sitting on the
precipice of losing the Senate losing
one one Georgia senate seat
cost us within the first three months of
the buying Administration two trillion
dollars yeah it was followed up by
another 1.2 trillion dollars and then
this year
740 billion dollars of more spending so
one one simple Georgia senate seat cost
all the American people amen nearly four
trillion dollars one seed in Georgia
added to this we now have 31 trillion in
debt yes did you ever think Herschel one
of the big issues to me is energy it's
the life out of the world's economy you
see I I find it embarrassing for our
country with all of our natural
resources we got hundreds hundreds of
years worth and we're begging Saudi
Arabia we're begging OPEC begging
Venezuela we're begging the the mullers
in Iran we're going to make them rich
and we're going to stay poor and it's
bad for National Security we're losing
High pay paying career jobs we pay a lot
less at at the pump if we if we produced
it here cheaper to heat our homes every
item we buy in every store we'd go to
would be cheaper yes and this is the
insanity now of this entire democratic's
party they're that radical I don't know
whether they even know that because
we're not even talking about the
reserves we got to mention the reserves
as well because you know we're right now
they've already given up more reserves
than any president combined and we're
we're at a crisis time and yet they
doesn't care because they don't care
about the people in the audience they
don't care about the people watching and
I said that's the problem they're doing
this over and over we're at a national
security problem right now and it seemed
like they're just it's going on telling
you this is a new normal well I'm here
to tell you this is not the new normal
Lindsay
when you look at this senatorial map
I'll be honest I'm not worried about
your race or John Kennedy's race or Rand
Paul's race I know you don't take any
vote for granted yes sir yeah I think
I'm not taking but we've you look at
every state and play here we got Florida
Georgia North and South Carolina we got
New Hampshire we got Pennsylvania we got
Ohio we got Ron Johnson in Wisconsin
we've got uh Missouri we've got Nevada
we've got uh Arizona you can add to that
maybe Colorado maybe Washington state
right so these are every one of these
races are impactful but they're not easy
these are this is going to be a tough
election from my perspective for the
Senate okay so let's look at it this way
if we pick up one more seat as I've said
about a thousand times all the crap all
the madness stops right it could be the
road to the majority runs through
Georgia right yes do you believe that
America's on the wrong track
do you are you willing to do something
about it oh yeah all right well
take your friends and if you don't have
a friend go make one
get everybody you know to vote vote
legally but vote in Georgia and if
you're at home wanting to help him who
gets the hell beat out of him every day
close the money Gap the last time I was
on your show we raised over three
hundred thousand dollars just like that
there's about two and a half to three
million people watching tonight and if
just a fraction of it went to then went
to a little bit more okay for me
whatever it is I hope it's a hundred
million but if you just went and went to
team herschel.com and gave 20 bucks it
closes the Gap I know I'm a one-trick
pony here's Biden's America you gotta
mortgage your house
to fill up your car to go to the gas
station you're probably gonna get robbed
we need to end this yes and it can be
ended here in Georgia if Herschel wins
and they know this
it's over that's why they're trying to
destroy his life trying to destroy his
family's life they tried to destroy
Kavanaugh's life so he would back down
and not be on the Supreme Court those
three Supreme Court justices have
changed America this man is not going to
back down he's not going to give in give
Herschel the ball he's the best bet for
Georgia he's the best bet for America
it really is all of that on the line
senator
and I don't seem like Georgia football
but I Love Her
Go Cox yeah so there's no doubt that
when you look at the midterms in my
lifetime there's not a more important
midterm for America's future than this
year we are just days away from putting
America back on the right track we have
to have the majority in the center
remember the good old days from 2016 to
2020. when we were in the majority we
put 300 conservative judges on the bench
three
three Supreme Court Justices on the
[ __ ] the firewall for America has been
our Judiciary we can change the course
of American History starting in Georgia
starting with Herschel by returning
Common Sense Insanity to the U.S Senate
it is that important let me let me ask
you a hard question
and this comes up quite a bit yes
if you are African-American
and you are a conservative
you get smeared slandered it's the in a
woke World in which we live I will tell
you it is the one thing you could just
tear anybody apart say anything Senator
Scott you lived through it you're living
through it well let me say this why does
it why don't we demand that that
character assassination and and forever
it should but it won't here's the truth
here's the truth
what Herschel represents what I
represent is not about it's not about me
and Herschel it's about every single
young man young woman who happens to be
a person of color who has conservative
leanings they want to say to those young
men
shut up they want to say to the young
ladies you be quiet because if if we can
lose if they can cut our throats
unfortunately it means every other young
person will be silent they will stand up
yes and fight for this country we will
not back down we love America
foreign
I'm trying to be the best Christian in
my life I can yeah and we're all
imperfect right right we're falling
short but I will tell you I just believe
very it's very simple for me God created
every man woman and child on this Earth
yes and put inside them Talent
you got a lot more than the rest of us
um but it but this is something that is
a pattern Clarence Thomas Senator Scott
Senator soon to be I almost said Senator
Herschel Walker yeah yeah
but but you even running you are a
threat to the establishment because why
is that and I and I say that because you
said because right now we must realize
that they will say and do anything to
retain power so it doesn't matter what
it is doesn't matter who they have to go
through they will say and do anything to
retain power but I told them early they
don't know who they mess with right now
right that's right God prepared me
God prepared me for this moment right
here and I told him I said guys y'all
were waking a grizzly bear now and now
you got to fight and I think Senator why
not saw it Friday night and I said he's
going to see it come November because
he's going to be leaving and you know
and I'm going to shake his hand because
he didn't want to shake my hand that
well when the rebate when the debate was
over but I'm gonna shake his hand as
he's walking out of the door got his ass
kicked that's why well I don't want to
say it like that I don't want to say it
like that but he got beat I think you
realize that but the thing is is this is
about Georgia it's about the people of
Georgia about the people of the United
States of America that right now we know
that there's a problem and the problem
is stems from Washington DC people that
don't seem to care about the people that
put them in office and I say it's time
for a change to happen if you're elected
you're promising the people of Georgia
I want to make sure I'm right lower
taxes controlled borders uh refund the
police get rid of the energy idiotic no
bad laws
you will support energy Independence and
you will support Reading Writing math
History Science yes and get rid of the
woke agenda yes and our military I want
to continue to say I will support our
military because our military is our
strength amen and we have to continue to
support our military all right hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else